Це Краматорський напрямок, а це Горлівський.
В липні 2014-го за це перехрестя біля селища Ямпіль Донецької області
точилися жорстокі бої.
Врешті територія залишилась за Україною, але
насичена мінами і тому поки непридатна для життя.
Мешканці чотирьох навколишніх селищ досі не ризикують сюди ходити.
Роботи з розмінування тривають тут два роки.
Ці жовті кілочки свідчать,
що боєприпаси вже вилучено, але навряд чи усі,
враховуючи те, що тут піщані ґрунти.
Цей район після розмінування візуально обстежили ЗСУ і МНС.
Все, що вони знайшли зверху, прибрали.
Тепер ми хочемо перевірити те, що увійшло в ґрунт і не вибухнуло.
Це сапери британської неурядової організації HALO Trust  -  демінери.
Вони перевіряють все, що перебуває на глибині 15 сантиметрів.
Крок за кроком, повільно та з максимальною концентрацією.
Спочатку таким детектором…
А потім вже ручним. Головне –
визначити, де має бути от ця червона фішка.
Щоб точно знати, де почати викопувати імовірний боєприпас.
Звідси, використовуючи різець і скребок,
демінер доходить до сигналу.
Якщо сигнал знайдений, він ідентифікується:
чи він вибухонебезпечний чи ні.
Наразі в прифронтових районах Донбасу працює сім команд HALO.
Минулого року демінери очистили територію в 60 гектарів.
Цього року роботи більше, і організація почала навчати новий персонал.
Керівник проектів Ніколас Торбент брав участь у розмінуванні країн Африки,
а також Лаосу і Камбоджі. Він вважає,
що очистити Донбас від мін і інших боєприпасів
Україна зможе не раніше, ніж за 10 років.
Вінпоказує знімальній групіDWодин з найскладніших
об’єктів у Ліманському районі.
Після боїв за цю річку "сюрпризи війни" тут
можуть бути під кожним деревцем.
Слід очистити пару тисяч квадратних метрів землі.
Це мають бути дві-три команди,
які зможуть це зробити за 6-7 місяців.
Від початку війни наДонбасі на боєприпасах
підірвалися майже півтори тисячі людей,
із них 200 загинули.
Розмінувати потрібно не менше 10 тисяч квадратних кілометрів.
Україні допомагають країни Європи.
Зокрема, Німеччина на діяльність HALO
виділила півтора мільйона євро
і надала необхідне обладнання.
Ось це –для пошуку пластикових мін.
В земліДонеччини таких може бути зараз багато.
І саме до їх пошуку HALO береться цього року.